now back when the nintendo 64 was still
in prototype the execs over nintendo did
a little bit of tricky marketing they
brought in a bunch of reporters put them
in a room that pretty much had a screen
rendering a little character on it and
then a little interesting black box in
front of them now the black box was
completely hidden all the reporters
could do was stick their hands inside
and fumble around with the controller
that was in it
after a while of playing with these
things one of the reporters said that
the controllers were so revolutionary it
was like his thoughts were being
extended right into the game which is a
great case in point if you get the
controls right the world plays along
with you get it wrong and
well i'm pretty sure you can guess what
happens then